the left worst week ever concludes with
them using the only weapon left at their
disposal calling conservatives bigots
from The Economist to Eric Holder to
Elon Omar when the left calls your
racist
you know you've won the argument then
Mike Lee gives a highly entertaining
green New Deal performance on the floor
of the Senate David Brooks is wrong in
the New York Times surprise surprise and
finally the mailbag I'm Michael Knowles
and this is the Michael no leo
[Music]
what a week what a week but all good
things must come to an end and the way
that the left is ending their week is by
using their last resort their last ditch
when they have no argument they have no
evidence they have egg on their face for
two years what do they do they call you
a bigot we will get to those very sad
strategies but first let's make a little
money honey with purple mattress oh I've
got a little purple mattress story so
sweet little Elise is out of town and so
I've got this giant beautiful California
King purple mattress all to myself look
it's been a long week I've been
traveling a lot that alarm goes off this
morning I could not bring myself to get
out of my purple mattress I snoozed and
I snoozed and it was absolutely lovely
purple mattress is what you've got to
try to get a good night's sleep the
founders of purple are these two
brothers who have been developing
cushioning technology for 30 years
purple mattress will feel different than
anything you've ever slept on because
it's not quite a it's not an innerspring
it's not a memory foam it's this new
technology it's both firm and soft at
the same time how is that possible I
don't know I couldn't tell you I'm not a
rocket scientist but people who designed
purple mattress are rocket scientists it
is so nice there's a hundred night risk
free trial if you're not fully satisfied
you can return your mattress for a full
refund backed by a 10-year warranty free
shipping and returns you're gonna love
purple right now my listeners get a free
purple pillow with the purchase of a
mattress that's in addition to the great
free gifts they offer site-wide just
text knowles KO wles to eight four eight
eight eight the only way to get this
free pillows to text knowles can or wles
two eight four eight eight eight k nowl
es eight four eight eight eight message
and data rates may apply so i've got to
give it to him i held out for a long
time but been Shapiro's booked the right
side of history has topped number one on
the New York Times bestseller list we've
been going back and forth we've been
talking about this so your book was
number one on Amazon oh that's good
mine was number one on Amazon for 11
days but no it's okay no but that's good
that's good now we have I thought there
was no way that the New Year
time's was gonna give it to him because
they hate his guts as we'll see in just
one second but this book sold so many
copies so fast it reached number one on
the New York Times bestseller list it is
selling it out like crazy it is a really
good book I read it when it was in draft
form I've been going to college campuses
since the book is released people bring
me the book I say did you read that yet
this is like an entire history of an
intellectual history of Western
civilization
they say you bet I read it in two days
couldn't put it down gotta give it to
the guy number one on the New York Times
bestseller list that is a huge deal that
is really cool so go ahead and buy the
book if you haven't bought it yet the
other reason you have to buy it is
because the left is furious about this
book they are so upset The Economist
published a headline today quote inside
the mind of ben shapiro
the alt-right sage without the rage ben
shapiro alt-right sage
now they went inside his mind apparently
they didn't look at his head on the top
of which is a yarmulke which is good
evidence that you're not a part of the
alternative right this is has there's a
lot going on in this headline to begin
first of all it's just not true right
bet Ben has been very clear in his
condemnation of the alternative right
and they just use this smear so an
McEvoy I guess is the editor of The
Economist when she said Ben in fairness
we said and then she has some
misspellings or something I think she'd
say you're like a figure in all
right-thinking
but that's not really a label she's
saying we didn't label you all right
we're just saying it's sort of like
you're in the alt-right thinking so it I
would like to point out that Ann McEvoy
is a Nazi pedophile
Ann McEvoy the editor of The Economist
is a Nazi pedophile but I'm not labeling
her a Nazi pedophile I'm just saying
she's a Nazi pedophile but don't you
accuse me of labeling her that way
because this first of all that statement
and McAvoy is a Nazi pedophile is as
much of a label and it's as accurate as
the Economist
line that ben shapiro is an all right
sage now this thing got ratioed into
oblivion people were both rightly quite
angry about this and just making fun of
them for what shoddy ridiculously
sophomoric journalism they made so they
did release a correction they say quote
a previous version mistakenly described
mr. shapiro as an old dried sage and a
pop idol of the alt-right in fact he has
been strongly critical of the old right
movement we apologize so there it is big
headline big tweet and then hours and
hours later when no one's gonna read it
they have a little correction down there
that's what they do what's so funny to
in this is they criticize Ben for using
clicky headlines to get people to come
engage with his content they did a far
more egregious version of that than
banner The Daily wire any of us have
ever done but I don't I'm not saying
this to defend Ben can defend himself
he's a big boy and I'm not doing this
just to make fun of The Economist if we
were gonna do that we'd be here all day
long the reason I bring it up is is
because this is what the left does with
language Ben is an alt right sage by the
way that the left uses the term the alt
right I guess he is I guess anybody to
the right of Hillary Clinton is alt
right this is what they do this is why I
actually don't use that phrase anymore
I did a Prager you video when the
alternative right was being brought up
as a new topic of discussion just to
make clear what the alternative right is
why it's wrong and why we should move on
then the left took that term and they
watered it down to me nothing so now I
don't use the term I try to be much more
precise I don't use the term racist too
frequently because what does it mean it
had a meaning then the left robbed it of
meaning so now I try to be more specific
I'll say racially bigoted bigotry at
least has a meaning for now at least it
still has not been robbed of its meaning
this is what the left does the term
alt-right has been robbed of its meaning
and it's too bad because there is an
idiot
that that term once described an
alternative to conservative thought and
what it was really specifically being
used by by its biggest proponents is a
politics that essentially boils down to
race and ethnicity without much regard
for well I am the one hand without much
regard to values or traditional civic
nationalism whatever okay that's one
side of it but what where I really
object is its without regard to culture
and religion and God so you're taking
all the trappings of christened dumb but
you're robbing it of the Christ and so
what is that that's a sick perversion I
mean that's why I reject it as I
explained to my Prague review video now
that term has been robbed of any meaning
so I don't use it because I'm not gonna
give the left any opportunity if people
say this I hear this every everywhere
from left wing commentators they'll use
it in passing conversation to dummies on
the street they'll say this is a halt
right all right you don't know what that
is you don't know what that means
so they do it all the time during the
Bush years they did this with the term
neocon do you remember some of you were
too young to remember all you'd hear
during the butcher's neocon Nyoka is a
neocon neoconservative once had a
meaning it was a movement popularized by
Bill crisp there bill Bill Kristol by
irving kristol bill crystals father and
it was described as liberals who were
mugged by reality socialists who were
mugged by reality this turn during the
1960's of people who would have called
themselves liberals some who were really
far left to see the realities of
communism and international socialism to
become more conservative at least with
the approach to foreign policy and many
of them came along with a conservative
approach to domestic policy as well this
was robbed of meaning during the Bush
years and now the term is useless you
keep to call someone in neocon what does
that even mean anymore now when they use
the phrase they mean bigoted war mongers
people who want to bomb brown people
what does the term alt-right mean it
means anyone to the right of Hillary
Clinton is a racist bigoted bigoted
bigoted bigoted and this brings us to
the best week ever for the right the
worst week ever for the left and
last thing they can possibly do which is
call everybody a bigot you know in
conversations you'll say yeah I think we
should I think we should lower the top
marginal tax rate bring it down a little
bit I'll be good for the economy that'll
help everybody they'll say well but but
but and once they finally run out of
arguments they'll say well the reason
you want to do that is because you're a
racist
yeah I think we should modify our
environmental policy I don't think we
should over regulate businesses too much
butt butt butt butt butt butt butt
you're a racist that's always the bottom
of the of the argument and that's what
you're seeing here you're not just
seeing it from the Economist which can't
argue with Ben can't argue with the book
so they just call him a bigot you see
this with Eric Holder former attorney
General Eric Holder came out he was
doing an interview on MSNBC and they
were talking about the Muller probe the
Russia investigation DOJ more broadly
and he couldn't defend his legacy he
can't defend two years of ridiculous
hoax narrative on the so-called Russian
collusion so what does he do he accuses
everybody of racism I'm thinking about
the judges who assess to Paul Manafort
and as you know the people who said oh
well one of the judges was good and the
other wasn't
but both judges assessed him as this
sort of courtly grandfatherly figure
judge Jackson said that he didn't seem
likely to Rhea fend her mana for had
reoffended after his charges and I
thought would any judge again I don't
want to single a single judge out but
would those judges be as likely to say
that about a first-time young black male
offender you know I don't talk about the
judges those judges in particular but I
do worry that judges like everybody
Americans carry with them implicit
biases and especially in the criminal
justice fear how do you fix it well you
certainly have to have training
people aware of the fact that they do
carry these biases and make them
understand that you know if you see an
african-american defendant in front of
you that's gonna probably trigger things
in your mind
unconsciously subconsciously and you're
perhaps gonna treat that person
differently than somebody who shows up
in a tie and has you know a great lawyer
that they have paid for
you're gonna maybe cut that person a
break that you wouldn't otherwise give
to a Hispanic or african-american
defendant implicit biases this is this
is the great crown jewel of sneering
people as racist because they can't do
anything about it because it's implicit
it's subconscious you can't consciously
change it because it's subconscious also
by the way if you didn't catch that at
the end Eric Holder says the reason that
you that african-american people and
Hispanic people are treated unfairly is
because if you see somebody wearing a
tie you're gonna give them a greater
respect and credit because apparently
according to Eric Holder a black man who
is wearing a tie black people and
Hispanic people can't put on a tie you
see is conflating race and knowing had a
dress in a respectful situation Oh black
people in Hispanic they can't wear ties
Eric you're wearing a tied no but this
oh no no no no nothing to see here
that's your implicit bias that thinks
I'm wearing a tie it's all implicit
implicit implicit we'll see in just one
second why this is the weakest of the
racist arguments but first let's make a
little money honey what keeps listen
fellas
losing hair is no good I am NOT an a
Greek Adonis of a man I am NOT some old
ancient hero not the most athletic fella
but one thing I've always had going for
me in the ladies department is my head
of hair two out of three guys will
experience hair loss by the time they're
35 which brings us to keeps the easiest
and most affordable way to keep the hair
you have these fda-approved products
used to cost a lot of money but now
thanks to keeps they're finally
inexpensive they're easy to get for five
minutes now starting at just 10 bucks a
month less than thirty three point three
three cents per day is that right - I do
that number right I think
maybe you will never have to worry about
hair loss again just getting started
with keeps this very easy sign up takes
less than five minutes
answer a few questions a licensed
physician will review your information
online and recommend the right treatment
for you then it's shipped right to your
door every three months keeps offers
generic versions of the only two
fda-approved hair loss products out
there ten to thirty five bucks a month
plus now you get your first month free
one fabulous way to keep your hair
receive your first month of treatment
for free go to keeps calm / Noles KO
wles
ke eps calm / knowles candor wles guys
that you are gonna kick yourself if you
allow hair loss to begin when you could
have stopped it so easily and for such
little money free month of treatment it
keeps calm / Knowles keeps here today
hair tomorrow the implicit biases this
is just we're not aware of it we're just
kind of robots moving with our racial
bigotry inside of us that's why any time
the left loses it's because of that
because of this mythical implicit bias
by the way the studies on so-called
implicit biases very very weak not a
whole lot of it evidence for this
phenomenon but did you see what Eric
Holder said I said well how do we combat
these implicit biases it says well you
need a lot of training you need a lot of
training you need reeducation you need
brainwashing what this means is that in
institutions that the federal government
touches that the left touches you are
going to have to go through mandated
re-education and brainwashing of leftist
ideology and you see this everywhere
this happens all over anywhere that
there is an institution in America with
any relation to the left or the
government they have this universities
you have to go through mandatory
trainings diversity training sensitivity
training implicit bias training in
corporate America the same is true some
of the things I see from my friends in
the Academy is absurd you'll see they're
constantly getting emails about this
constantly getting trainings about this
sort of thing that's what he wants this
is the
this is why the government is always
trying to come in K through 12 education
pre-k education they want hey we'll give
you free education
hey we'll subsidize your student loans
hey we'll give universities a ton of
money but come on we're giving you all
you've got to give us a little something
do this training do this
re-education through this brainwashing
that's what he wants that's what we're
talking about why because they don't
have the argument so they've got to come
in Nancy Pelosi said this the other day
we need to lower the voting age to 16 so
that we can capture them when they're
already in our grip in public education
and so now we've got Eric Holder this is
not just some wacko elected official or
just some wacko activist this is a guy
who was the Attorney General is this a
major political figure in the country
now we have Alon Omar Alana mammarra
elected Democrat freshman Democrat
representative doesn't like the Jews
very much has made many comments
repeatedly with weak apologies and then
repeated slurs against Jews her
communications director what does he say
he posts on Twitter the other day Jeremy
sleeve on quote anti-semitism is a
right-wing force anti-semitism is a
right-wing force anti-semitism is a
right-wing with this what they do this
is the new left thing for leftist tweets
they'll either repeat some empty slogan
time and time again they had one Planned
Parenthood tweeted out something like
some men have a uterus some men have a
uterus because they think if they repeat
it enough times it makes fantasy true
and so they do this here the other one
they do is they use the clapping sign
they do the clapping uh anti-semitism is
a right-wing force and he's saying this
because his boss is an anti-semite again
language has been watered down so much I
don't use the term a lot I don't use it
to apply to a lot of people but she has
expressed this time and time again
she said Israel is hypnotized the world
she's prayed to Allah to wake people up
to the evils of Israel she said the only
reason anybody in America would support
Israel is because they're getting paid
off by Jews she has said that the only
the reason that we have to treat Israel
so differently is that Jews in America
can
be trusted not to have dual loyalties
they can't be trusted to be loyal to
their own country she is an anti-semite
and what this guy Jeremy Sleeman is
trying to do is convince everybody than
its opposite day you're I knew I know
you are but what am i that's what he's
saying because they've had the worst
week ever and for Alana Omar this has
been the worst month ever sheis she's
been roundly condemned even by her own
party this is one of the reactions to
the best week ever that we noted last
time which is gaslighting they're trying
to Gaslight us they're trying to say no
no no the russia probe that wasn't
legitimate it was caused by racism no no
no the bigotry of members of our own
party it's actually opposite day it's
actually your bigotry no no no ben
shapiro in his book which is all just
about western intellectual history and
it's selling in its number one on the
New York Times list it's only number one
cuz he's a big racist and everybody's a
racist lalala every everybody who
doesn't agree with me is a bigot
everyone who doesn't agree with me is
Hitler lalalalala that is the only
conclusion that we could have expected
from this week it's a wonderful way to
end the week we knew it was going to
happen so I just like to toast all of
you who have your leftist ears tumblers
out that is the natural conclusion when
the left calls you a racist
you know you've won the argument
speaking of race frauds
jussie Smollett the guy who gave a good
acting performance on Empire and a bad
acting performance on the streets of
Chicago you know he just had his charges
dropped by the crooked Cook County State
Attorney's Office you know he's trying
to say he's been totally cleared now I
mentioned this just a day or two ago I
said this is not the end for Jesse
Smollett they would be crazy to bring
him back on that show Empire because he
faces federal charges so ok he gets off
in crooked Cook County the big issue is
he sent himself a hate hoax a threat
hoax he sent it through the mail that
makes it a federal crime and I said it
the other day the feds are not going to
take kindly to crooked Chicago politics
they're not gonna let this off the
and looks like I was right we are now
finding out that the feds are not only
looking into the deal that was reached
in Chicago they're also looking into
federal charges of mail fraud the FBI is
investigating whether or not justice
Millette sent the hate mail to himself
this was laced with a white powder so it
was a real threat and if he is convicted
of this Jesse's smollett could face up
to a decade in prison what did they say
they get called that Jesse Smollett
called out as a total fraud a total hoax
and he he says no no it was no it's
racism its anti-gay I would never do I
would never do that and that works a
little bit it can work in the short run
it will not work in the long run
reality eventually reasserts itself
we're seeing it again and speaking of
racial politics this this last one might
be the most ridiculous part of the whole
day Stacey Abrams who is a failed
gubernatorial candidate in Georgia
Stacey Abrams whose only job that she's
ever had as far as I can tell is being
in the Georgia state government that's
her only political experience she is now
being heralded by weirdos on the left as
a potential 2020 candidate here's Andrea
Mitchell asking why she is not at the
top of the pack how do you feel about
the some of the white men who were
running being asked about a running mate
and sang up that they would guarantee
putting a woman on the ticket
you and Andrew Gilliam came way closer
to winning your races than better a look
did how do you feel about all the
publicity the campaign that that or work
has has gained by the listening tour you
know cooking at home going to the
dentist his online presence his
fundraising why better award can not
Andrew Gilliam and not Stacey Abrams as
you know the darling of the media
yeah Beto's a weirdo - but why Stacey
Abrams she's nobody she is nothing she
was in the Georgia State Assembly or
something are you kidding me that
qualifies you to be President she lost
an election
she lost her election for
govenor she then didn't concede the
election she then finally conceded but
she says it was all wrong and now
there's a rumor that Joe Biden might
announce her as his running mate and oh
the mainstream media are so excited
about this during that lunch with the
vice president let me ask you did the
conversation of a potential future
ticket between the two of you with Vice
President you being his vice president
on the ticket one quick rather piece of
political business you said you've been
meeting with and having drinks with
everybody was thinking about running for
president when you drink alone are you
having somebody running for president is
there are a number of women there are a
number of minority candidates running
for the Democratic nomination is this
the year one of them ends up being the
nominee I believe so this is head this
is the I believe so I'm Stacy Abrams I
was in the knew I was in the Georgia
State House in the State Assembly for
like a little while so that's why I
should be President this is how you know
that not just on Russia and not just on
Jessie small aDNA just not just on the
alone anymore
this is how you know broadly nationally
the left has lost the argument is the
only thing that can play is racism the
fact that this woman who has done
nothing in her life is being considered
as a legitimate presidential candidate
couldn't even win at governor's race
down there tells you everything why is
she being considered a serious candidate
because she's a black woman there's
nothing bigoted about pointing that out
these guys admit it themselves all of
those interviews say well but you're
you're a racial minority you're a woman
what shouldn't you be considered a
candidate you're you're better than beta
or work shouldn't you shouldn't you by
virtue of your sex and race become the
presidential candidate and this is
really bad because this is always the
case when you only focus on race and sex
when you when that's the bottom of your
argument you don't have an argument and
the Democrats if they want to win in
2020 need to have an argument they need
to present some reason to the American
people to vote for them they need to say
Trump has done this wrong we're gonna do
this right here's what we're gonna offer
they have nothing to offer they have
nothing to offer other than the green
New Deal which Michael Lee came out
yesterday and had one of the most
hilarious routines on the floor of the
Senate is one of the best presentations
there
he started showing photos of Ronald
Reagan shooting machine guns on a
velociraptor he said this is as serious
as the green new deal and he's right
we've got to get to the mailbag but
before we go I just want to point
something out from David Brooks David
Brooks
this is the real cap to the best week
ever he wrote a piece in the New York
Times said we've all just made fools of
ourselves again we've all made fools of
ourselves because of all the Russia's
stuff and everything calls it the awful
corruption of scandal politics he says
quote maybe it's time to declare a
national Sabbath maybe it's time to step
back from the scandal mongering and
assess who we are right now Democrats
might approach this moment with an
attitude of humility and honest
self-examination it's clear that many
Democrats make Grievous accusations
against the president that are not
supported by the evidence
it's clear that people like bait OA
Rourke and John Brennan Oh Donald Trump
a public apology Republicans and the
sean hannity style Trump Ian's might
also approach this moment with an
attitude of humility and honest
self-examination for two years they've
been calling the Muller investigation a
witch hunt for two years they've been
spreading the libel that there are no
honest brokers in Washington they should
apologize for peddling that sort of deep
cynicism that undermines our country's
institutions no no no no you don't get
to do this the left doesn't get to do
this there is no moral equivalence the
left is said for two years Donald Trump
is a stooge a tool of Russia a traitor
to his country who sold our whole
country out and now we're a satellite
state for the Kremlin that was totally
wrong every syllable of that was wrong
and it was proven wrong also for two
years conservatives have said there was
no basis for this investigation we know
that it was crooked from the beginning
because it was based on a fake dossier
funded by Hillary Clinton with massive
FISA abuse massive collusion between the
Democrats the Obama DOJ and FBI and
foreign intelligence sources including
in Russia we said this was crooked from
the very beginning and so we are
skeptical of the investigation because
of hard evidence which we still have
which is still demonstrable that this
investigation never should have been
launched
the first place there is no moral
equivalence we were right we were 100%
exonerated not just on Donald Trump
being not being a stooge of Russia not
just on Donald Trump not obstructing
justice but us we were exonerated in our
deep skepticism and our deep opposition
to this Russian hoax investigation
because it was wrong it was a lie it was
a total fiction and fantasy from the
very beginning no equivalence the left
owes an apology to us we owe an apology
to absolutely nobody including David
Brooks we win you lose deal with it
we've got to get to the mailbag go to
Daley wire calm right now coming up at
7:00 p.m. Eastern 4 p.m. Pacific tune
into our next episode of daily wire
backstage where I'm gonna smoke a cigar
and have a glass of whiskey because I'm
a little riled up by this silly
equivalence this ridiculous attempt just
say well we both did something wrong
nope best week ever for Republicans
worst week ever for Democrats deal with
it we're gonna celebrate tonight it's
gonna be me Jeremy
Ben Shapiro Andrew Clavin and this
week's special guest Matt Walsh it's
gonna be a lot of fun as always only
daily wire subscribers get to ask the
questions and if you subscribe during
tonight's live stream you will be
automatically entered to win a visit to
daily wire and sit in on a future
episode of backstage meet us watch the
show we're gonna have a great time
subscribe to daily wire tonight during
the live stream and be automatically
entered to win the sweepstakes trust me
we will have a very good time you know
what you get you get everything if you
weren't already a subscriber you'd have
drowned all week go to daily wire com
we'll be right back with the mailbag
running late as always but we are gonna
get through this mail back from kami hi
Michael my husband and I are having a
problem in our marriage and would like
your opinion while everything is mostly
going well we cannot decide who is at a
greater risk of drowning given all of
the latest news unfortunately we only
have one leftist here's tumblr what
should we do
please help the obvious answer is to
subscribe again it's the only way to
save both of you if you don't have time
to do that if you're not watching the
backstage livestream tonight you're not
entering you're not subscribing to enter
to win a chance to come out here and
hang out with us during the next
backstage women and children first
sir that's just the up right thing to do
especially in a week like this with so
many tsunamis next question from Elliot
hi Michael at 29 you have your life
together and have achieved a lot more
than many liberals do even into their
40s it is true not writing a book is a
far greater achievement than many of our
friends on the Left will ever will ever
have while they're whining and screaming
for two years straight what do you think
separates you and many other young
successful conservatives from liberals
who at 29 are still figuring themselves
out whatever that means and over 29 it's
funny you ask that when I was a kid I
vividly remember this I was 8 or 9 years
old and I was watching The Wonder Years
and I heard the phrase about Kevin's
older sister he said she's just finding
herself said what the hell does that
finding yourself well you got a look
you're right there you've got you and
find find yourself right there I thought
I was when I knew I was really a
conservative and so I appreciate the
compliment that things are have have
gone well for me the main reason things
have gone well is the holy unmerited
grace of God that's and just wonderful
Providence before which I am awed that's
the main answer however in so much as we
can help help ourselves out god helps
those who help themselves I think a big
difference between conservative
and left-wingers we know broadly that
conservatives are more content have more
life satisfaction or happier and more
joyful this is this is true it has been
seen in many many social scientific
studies it's not just true in the United
States it's true around the world there
is a huge meta-analysis of this taking
into account sixteen countries tens of
thousands of people in it remain true
why is that I think the main issue is
that conservatives see purpose in the
world for conservatives who are drawing
on the tradition even if you would call
yourself secular or agnostic you're
drawing on a tradition which is
Christian and so you see purpose in the
world you are accessing that even by way
of your culture and your behavior and
it's it's a far greater encouragement to
live life well or to try to live life
well or to try to thrive and to try to
flourish if you understand that life has
a purpose and there is a moral law and
there is Redemption and resurrection and
there is a God who created it all who
sees it all and the alternative view to
that is that as Hamlet says life is a
tale told by an idiot full of sound and
fury signifying nothing that's a pretty
depressing why would you get out of bed
why would you do anything other than
scream at the chaos why do conservatives
why are we resilient when we lose
elections when why does the left never
concede elections because to them this
is just total chaos this is just tono
know ripping their hair out but for
conservatives we say well that's the way
the world it's a fallen world these
things happen but ultimately there is a
divine justice that prevails
that's probably at the at the base the
reason you can add on a lot of culture
and politics and behaviors on top of
that but I think that's what lays at the
base of it from Peter question nickname
for bado
Plato Bejo
he is soft childlike and easily
manipulated what do you think and can
you tweet this at the president I don't
have Twitter it's clever but it's a
terrible nickname it's not gonna work it
doesn't stick this is what conservatives
do a lot we overthink it we are too
clever by half senator Ted Cruz whom I
greatly admire he's a little too clever
by half sometimes Donald Trump
understands not to be Donald Trump the
reason he's so great at nicknames is he
just punches people right in the gut a
great example of this is Elizabeth
Warren the nickname for her before
President Trump adopted it was focus on
ttis f aux Cantus this is a play on
words faux meaning false and Pocahontas
it's clever it's pretty good laia wathah
that's pretty it's a lie and Hiawatha
okay these are these are good nicknames
but President Trump didn't go for Foca
hunt as he went for Pocahontas which is
not a double entendre it's just he's
just calling her the most famous Indian
name and that's it but that was the
better nickname even though it's less
clever because of that nickname paints a
picture it's direct it doesn't require
that you know what the word faux means
it doesn't require you to put together
this this play on words to look at the
juxtaposition of those two words it's
clear it's right to the point
played obeyed oh sure he's soft and he's
weird and he's childlike but it's not
gonna go right to the point we've got to
wait for the master of nicknames himself
President Trump to get to it from ELISA
hello Michael
do you have any universities you're
planning on speaking at in Texas in the
near future if so where and when
yes I'm going to be down at Texas A&M
with none other than Andrew Clavin we're
gonna be doing a joint event down there
I think that's coming up in April I
don't have the exact date but check it
out at young America's Foundation you
can see my hole speaking tour there and
figure out where I'll be at a university
near you but I will be down I think next
month with drew so check it out from
Katya I'm Michael I just turned 18 last
Monday
I'm super excited because I get to vote
even though I heard your explanation of
why voting isn't inherently good my
co-workers however think I'm naive
because our votes don't mean anything
how would you respond to this I'd look
at the Senate race down in Florida look
at the governor's race down in Florida I
look at the governor's race that beat
out Stacey Abrams down in Georgia look
at the 2000 presidential election
sometimes elections come down to
hundreds of votes or less your vote
often does matter quite a lot voting is
not the be-all and end-all we don't have
a republic so that we can vote but we do
vote so that we can have a good republic
and if you've got good opinions and
you're supporting a good side of
politics you better make sure you go out
there and vote it certainly can matter
and in recent years it frequently has
from Bryce dear Michael I'm currently
writing a book about my experiences as a
male domestic abuse victim and I'm
trying to think of a great title that
not only will get attention but will
rile up the left I'm considering naming
it hashtag me too but friends I've
discussed this with have given this a
stir no there's a best-selling book
title author what say you
I'm open to any and all suggestions
thank you for acknowledging my expertise
obviously I know nothing about writing a
book but I know a lot about writing
titles I would say I assume they
objected to me too because it's so
controversial so I like keep that idea I
mean you should be controversial if you
want people to take a look at the
content and then hopefully you'll have
good content I would recommend not me
too but men too
hashtag men to the the male victims of
female brutality or of of sexual assault
or something to that effect I think
that's a good title
it would have the controversy it gets
your point across directly and no one's
written it yet so I think that would be
a very interesting book from Michael
brother Michael I need your love guru
advice two months ago I started dating
one of my friends of three years she
moved to Nashville six months ago and
agreed to start a relationship only if I
plan to move to Nashville I agreed to
eventually if it worked out she wants me
to give her a date on when I play
to move but I have so many
responsibilities keeping me home is it
too much to ask of a significant other
to move across the country after two
months of a relationship best Michael
man what has happened to young love what
is wrong with you people listen to this
language we agreed to have a
relationship we sat down would you have
a negotiation you said across the table
you're so cam well and then but you've
got to move and you have to give me a
date but I've got responsibilities and
I've got what are you are you kidding me
I think it was George will made fun of
this one time from the perspective of
Cole Porter Cole Porter didn't sing
let's do it let's be in a relationship
that we negotiate and eventually all
plan to move once my responsibilities
are over no he said let's do it let's
fall in love come on man I don't know do
you want to do you like her first of all
you haven't been dating for two months
you said your friends were there for
three years three years you haven't come
to a conclusion I'm not saying you got
to move there I'm not saying you got to
move there even to continue dating one
another I've done long-distance for a
long time I've done that and I'm on the
road all the time now so I'm practically
long-distance for half the week but
don't be motivated by it well I've got
these responsibilities and well I oh you
know it's just really we were planning
and we negotiated and what's the time
don't do that
do you are you moved by a great feeling
of love do you do you love the girls do
you want to go yeah then go do it go see
her a lot and don't negotiate it out and
if you're not if it's just some kind of
clinical thing and it was a love affair
of convenience then break it off and do
something else but don't approach it in
this cold way that's it's like leftist
rationalist types do this they're
weighing out the pros and con don't do
that conservatives don't forget
Edmund Burke inspired all of the
romantics the Conservatives were
romantics in many ways be a romantic
from Timothy dear Michael master of
brevity does the 13th amendment prevent
us from owning the lives regards Chuck
this is a highly controversial issue of
constitutional law
the 13th amendment which outlaws slavery
may in fact prevent us from owning the
libs this will probably make it up to
the Supreme Court eventually and and
they'll give us a final judgement on it
the one thing we do know though is that
the Thirteenth Amendment does not
prevent the libs from owning themselves
at which they have done all week long
they've done this for over two years
they've done it for longer than two
years they are owning themselves and I
think this will be the great great
defense in this 13th Amendment argument
over if they can own themselves we might
as well not be left out of the fun I
think that actually would create a
discrimination case because if they can
own themselves why can't we own them as
well when you're so obviously owned
great question really thoughtful from
Brandon hey Michael what would your
opinion be about a conservative Church
as a business people would pay to hear a
sermon and worship God then learn about
ideas and great people like Aristotle
the reason being regular churches can't
speak on politics so they end up being
an LG b QP LMNOP meeting sometimes where
the heart of faith and ideology is never
discussed because they have to dance
around everyone's feelings I think it's
probably a bad idea to turn churches
into businesses
I remember reading something about only
being able to serve one master and not
being able to serve God and Mammon at
the same time so that and frankly the
problem with churches many churches
today is obviously many Protestant
churches but even many parishes of the
Catholic Church certainly in America is
that they are treating it like a
business they're treating it like
they're responding to market forces and
if the parish the congregation they're
not really a congregation they're just
the audience and we've got to give the
audience what they want we got to put on
a show for them and we got to tell them
exactly what they want to hear that's
the only way they'll fill up those pews
that's the only way they'll fill up that
donation basket the problem is we're
treating churches too much like a
business now if you want churches to be
able to talk about politics I agree I
think it's absurd
churches can't talk about politics and I
hope they changed that soon hopefully
they change it during the Trump
administration that has been bandied
about as an idea and I hope they do it
from Kyle dear big Papa Knowles is the
hot dog of sandwich yes yes it is from
Nathan Knowles hello I have recently
been interested in the creationism
versus theistic evolution debate where
do you come down on the issue and do you
think churches should teach one way or
the other thanks big fan of the show
Nathan I know that the books of the
Bible take into account all genres
they're not just written like modern
histories are written that's a that's
just a huge interpretive mistake of
certain church movements in the last 60
years or so
mostly I don't care though because as
Cardinal Boronia said the scripture
teaches us how to go to heaven not how
the heavens go CS Lewis was of this
opinion that GK Chesterton was this of
this opinion it's justa Dazz a matter of
science as to how the human race has
come to be as it is I suppose as a
scientific matter I'm interested but as
a theological matter it doesn't doesn't
change one little thing for me from Eric
hey Michael you mentioned earlier this
week that you believe an Turkey to be of
the left I've been trying to think it
through and I'm just curious how you
would go about arguing that position
thanks
well because anarchy takes on the
primary premise of the left which is
that the chief unit of society is the
individual it takes on the idea of
social contracts which is an essentially
leftist and rationalist idea with no
relation to history whatsoever and so
the anarchists take the idea that
because the idle of society the atomic
unit of society is the individual then
we're all just a bunch of individuals
and there should be no government
whatsoever because we're all just
individuals the flipside of that
argument is that the atomic unit of
society is all individuals and that's
all we have and there are no other but
there's no more atomic unit of society
and so because we're all individuals we
ought to be all swept up
as individuals in the collective with a
super collectivist state two sides of
the same argument the conservative
response to that is that the individual
obviously is not the atomic unit of
society we obviously are not born into
just thin air from nothing with no bonds
tying us to anybody or anything
obviously we're born from women from our
mothers and we were conceived because of
the love between our mothers and our
fathers and they're not alone either
they've got families as well and they're
in certain places with certain cultures
and certain community organizations and
bonds of kinship and bonds of loyalty
and bonds of patriotism and not just
entitlement and not just rights but duty
and responsibility to those things
because we didn't create our own lives
is given to us is the greatest gift and
so we ought to be grateful for that we
ought to have veneration for that we
ought to give some credence to the
prescription of the tradition which is
not the oldest thing it's the newest
thing because it's survived through all
of the years it's not a anti-democrat
it's the greatest democracy of all
because it's the democracy of the dead
that ties us as we are tied to our
ancestors into our future generations
that's the conservative answer to two
sides of a rationalist and ultimately
left-wing argument all right that's our
show we got a lot more to get to but too
bad we'll get to it later check us out a
backstage today that will be happening
later on in the meantime I'm Michael
gnosis is the Michael Knowles show see
you later
[Music]
the Michael Noel's show is produced by
Robert Sterling executive producer
Jeremy Moore senior producer Jonathan
hey our supervising producer is Mathis
Glover and our technical producer is
Austin Stevens edited by Dani D'Amico
audio is mixed by Dylan case hair and
makeup is by Jessa alvera production
assistant Nick Sheehan the Michael
Noel's show is a daily wire production
copyright day Lee Weyer 2019 hey guys
over on the Matt Walsh show today a
brutal assault of a pro-life activist by
a pro-abortion extremist is getting of
course no attention in the media but I
want to give it some attention today and
also I want to give some attention to
the greater problem the epidemic of
pro-abortion extremists assaulting
pro-lifers it happens all the time and I
will show you some evidence of that
today on the show also Vox has come out
perhaps unsurprisingly in defense of
cardi B who admitted to drugging and
robbing men we'll talk about the double
standard there also we have the latest
on justice Millette all of that today
over on the Matt Walsh show